hi there steve kaufman here today i want
to talk about language learning apps
applications
uh software systems on your phone on
your
tablet even on your computer
that you can use that will help you
learn
a language
which which is the best
language learning app
all right before i start
let's
make it clear that you learn the
language from the language the language
teaches you the language all right
by consuming the language you learn the
language so the app is just a device to
help you
consume the language it's a bit like an
app is like a
bottle opener or a corkscrew that gets
rid of the cork so that you can drink
the wine you're going to enjoy the wine
all right the app is no more than just
the course group
so
when it comes and so to that extent
books starter books any book textbook
you name it is in a way an app it's a
an ability or at least it's it's a
device
that helps you access the language so
that you can learn the language from the
language i have a lot of experience with
language learning apps leaving aside the
ones that i have explored on the
internet i have so many books at home i
just grabbed the few that were within
reach here in my library so intermediate
cantonese
a book on cantonese written in chinese
so mandarin speakers
farsi
what do we got here
polish grammar i haven't yet started on
turkish
i speak japanese but i'm curious as to
what people have out there hebrew uh ro
asimil romanian
chesky kroc zakrokhem
what do we got here toeic for japanese
people
kbs korean material
living language greek what else we got
here italian grammar romanian
portuguese and that's just scratching
the surface of what i have at home some
of them i've used many of them i look at
some i get given to me
i would say some are useful some are
less useful
now with regard to apps on the internet
oh so
the most powerful app right away is
google
because you know not only do you have
google translate you have google text to
speech but you can google to find
whatever you need you can find
listening material reading material
grammar resources you can find
you know conjugation tables declension
tables whatever you need to find
relating to your language learning
activity you can find plus it gives you
these powerful tools like google
translate and google text to speech so i
use google a lot
if you google
the best language apps language learning
apps you will find a list and they'll
have duolingo on there and busu and
babel and memrise anki
and these lists are very subjective
because
typically they're going to have the 10
best when in fact there are hundreds and
hundreds of apps when i started learning
hebrew and
and arabic and i had to learn the
writing system i downloaded a lot of
apps most of them were useless i start
with the free apps and then i pay a few
dollars to get an app i didn't end up
using them at all
so but there's lots of them you kind of
have to sort through the ones that work
best for you
so my conclusion is other than the fact
that google is an all-powerful app
the next most
powerful app for language learning is
the one you like the best
period
i tried duolingo i didn't like it
the reason why the one you like the best
is the best
is because you have to
want to use it you have to use it a lot
and you have to continue using it
because language learning takes time you
know i'm into arabic now i'm going to be
a year or two with arabic and that's
based on my experience in learning
russian and learning czech and learning
all these other languages it takes time
so i have to you know
stay with an app for it to have any
benefit all right so and typically the
apps can only do a few different things
they may provide you with some grammar
rules they may
provide you with uh you know multiple
choice where you're deciding which is
the word for apple cow horse or pig you
know these kinds of things much like
rosetta stone does
duolingo provides you with a bunch of
disjointed phrases i didn't like
duolingo
uh because i couldn't control what i was
listening to and reading
uh memorize or anki are very much based
on flash cards and spaced repetition
systems so people who like to spend a
lot of time on that kind of activity are
going to enjoy those apps
uh
you won't be surprised to know that i
spent all my time with my link app
that's what i prefer to do other people
may prefer to do something else i do
that because i have
wonderful content all the functionality
that i need i prefer to spend most of my
time
reading and listening
and it enables me to access content
that's always that little bit more
difficult for me so i'm improving in the
language but that's me
and there are people who swear by
uh duolingo who swear by memorize anki
busu you name it it in a way doesn't
matter because language learning comes
down to
maintaining your level of motivation
and
spending the time so
if you enjoy the app you're using if you
feel you're making progress with this
app
and that can be a subjective thing you
may be in fact making progress and you
think you aren't
or you may think uh
that you're making a
a lot of progress
sorry we'll start from the beginning you
may think that you're not making
progress and you are in fact or you may
think that you're making progress and
you're not what matters is how you feel
about how you're doing if you feel good
about your language learning if you
enjoy the app
then you will stay with it and you will
eventually learn if you have a positive
attitude if you put in the time you will
eventually learn
that is why the best language learning
app is the one that you like one that
you like well enough to stay with it
thanks for listening bye for now
[Music]
you